Today, we are going to learn the parts of the house.
So I'm going to show you my apartment.
I hope you like it!
Just when we enter, there is a hall.
This is the corridor where all the rooms are.
Sleeping rooms are called bedrooms.
And here I have a study where I work.
This is the bathroom and the smaller one without a shower is the toilet.
If you are hungry, you can cook in the kitchen.
And this is the dining room with separated areas.
The table for dining and the living room.
My favorite site to take a nap because there are the armchairs and the television.
Up the stairs there's the attic.
And close by is a storage where I keep everything I do not use.
My apartment has a nice terrace with a beautiful view of the city.
Do you like my apartment?